So the propaganda games continue from the
White House.
They've now released a video where it is all
but completely obvious that a violent cough
by Donald Trump has been edited out of the
video and done really poorly.
This is part of the propaganda campaign that
they've been waging since Donald Trump went
to Walter Reed Hospital very quickly.
They sat Trump in front of a camera.
They had him deliver what they claimed was
a one take, very powerful four minute video
proving how well he's doing and how strong.
Yes, but it became immediately obvious that
at least at one point in this video, there
is what appears to be a jump cut.
Something appears to be just cut out.
And Donald Trump looks to be gagging when
it is done.
And the only logical conclusion we can reach
is that Trump coughing was removed from the
video.
So this is I acknowledge this is tough for
our audio audience.
You can find the video on my Twitter.
I'm going to first play the whole thing for
you.
And you'll notice that at the word therapeutics,
you hear something weird and you see Donald
Trump look almost like he's gagging or dry
heaving.
But it's very, very quick and it appears to
be a cough that was removed.
If you look closely, you'll also see Trump's
fingers jump because they did a poor job of
editing out the cough.
Take a look.
If you look at the therapeutics, which I'm
taking right now, some of the.
So now let's actually isolate the moment we're
talking about and play it without audio.
And again, I understand this is very visual
and that if you're only listening, it's hard
to understand what what we're seeing here.
But I did tweet this.
You can find it on my Twitter at David Pakman.
And as you can see, Trump seems to start to
gag or dry heave, but then it skips.
And Trump's finger twitches.
And so, as usual, the question is less about
the importance of this particular edit and
more about the constant gaslighting of the
American people to submit to to force them
to submit to a completely fabricated and concocted
narrative.
Trump's case of Corona virus has been stage
managed in a completely dishonest way for
optics and public relations appearances.
Christopher or is a contributing writer for
The Atlantic and Forbes tweeted that there
is clearly an edit on this video.
Experienced editors are saying that what is
in your dhobis suite called a Morfe cut tool
was used to remove Trump's violent cough from
the video.
So we need to be making sure that we're asking
the right questions when we talk about something
like this.
Why would the White House think they have
to do this?
Because of who Trump supporters are.
Trump can't just be sick from a serious virus.
That's not the right story.
Trump must be able to deliver four minutes
of uncut narrative to the audience about how
he's doing great.
Trump must not cough because for seven months,
more than that now, eight months, he's been
downplaying this as if it's no big deal.
Because if Trump was seriously ill, it probably
is the nail in the coffin of the approval
of Trump.
On Corona virus handling, which is already
very, very low.
If even Trump gets seriously ill, who could
be the most protected person in the world?
It also goes to the laziness of this administration
and of Donald Trump.
You could easily cover this by having Trump
stop.
Go back one line, film it from a different
angle, like from the side, for example.
It would look like a dramatic film making
decision and no one would be the wiser.
But they insist or Trump insists or Trump
is refusing to redo it.
They insist on doing the one take and then
cutting it out.
Cutting the cough out.
It is the most childish stage managing that
we've seen not only immoral to keep gaslighting
the American people about his condition, but
also done in a very unprofessional way.
It's a very childish, obvious, detectable
manner.
This is what we've gotten handed to us.
And this administration, I guess, thought
they could get away with it.
They didn't.
And they still think that they're going to
get away with getting this man reelected.
They may be right.
They may be wrong.
It is ultimately up to us to make sure that
it doesn't happen.
And that is why none of this means anything
other than go and vote.
There is not every news story.
Oh, there is a conflict in Armenia.
Oh, Trump's cutting out a cough from his video.
Oh, Joe Biden tested negative for rotavirus
a third time.
Fortunately, he did as of today.
It all means you go and you vote.
It all means you go to vote, dawg, and you
figure out my voting early in person.
Am I voting by mail?
Am I voting on November 3rd?
If so, where?
What are the rules?
Can somebody tell me that I need to get out
of line?
What what exactly is the plan?
That's all that we have to do.
We hear, oh, Trump's attacking China again.
We've
got
to vote.
That is
the
one answer here.